bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono poi j
oggi andiamo avanti con sergio un
simulator raga ho levato la mascherina
per il semplice motivo che praticamente
se metto la mascherina faccio un casino
col microfono perché filtro anti poco
più mascherina fa un casino assurdo ed
alla prossima puntata se riesco mi metto
pure il camice anche se morire di caldo
va beh è però la mascherina ho deciso di
toglierla perché non faceva troppo
casino
smettetela di chiamarmi quando lavoro
allora ragazzi l'ultima volta abbiamo
effettuato il trapianto di cuore che è
andato a buon fine
adesso dobbiamo effettuare il trapianto
di reni quindi state pronti e mi avete
anche detto che è con i floppy non ho
capito bene in che modo è possibile
sbloccarsi un'operazione nello spazio
addirittura c'è una cosa incredibile che
farò comunque alla fine raga voglio che
è diciamo gli episodi vadano di epico e
in epico nel senso che il grado di
epicità aumenti sempre di più quindi
raga il prossimo episodio sarà sul
trapianto di cervello
poi le ambulanze è poi il trapianto
nello spazio sarà fantastico a gravità
zero va bè direi di iniziare col
trapianto di reni allora rai che a voi
li conoscete sapete che il primo
trapianto del giorno non è mai quello
buono ma comunque apprestiamoci operare
come va a brutto stronzo tutto ok
oggi sei perfetto visto per operare
brutto stronzo
va bene assapora gli ultimi momenti
della tua vita allo ragazzi tutti i
futuri aspiranti chirurghi prestino
moltissima attenzione allora ragazzi
prima cosa bisogna lasciare l'orologio
in un posto dove non dà fastidio in modo
da avere sempre sott'occhio l'ora del
decesso nel caso succeda cosa molto
probabile
come seconda cosa ragazzi dato che è
latina cazzo ma inutile
dato che c'è una matita ma cazzo no mi
sto segnando una mano perfetto ragazzi
stavo rimettendo un arto bene dato che
c'è una matita disponibile ricordatevi
sempre prima di effettuare l'operazione
di firmare gli organi del paziente in
modo tale che quando lui va in giro si
ricordi del fatto che è stato però
sempre che se tornerà in giro che si
ricordi del fatto che avete operato voi
e se la matita si incastra nel pancreas
e lasciatela lì piuttosto va bene così
mi importa basta che la firma ci sia ma
che cazzo è dai togli occhi e perfetto
ce l'ho fatta bene la matita la prenda
al volo vai ho rotto una boccetta ma è
stato lui è stato voi io non c'entro
niente
e la colpa è sua la ripaga lui va bene i
re di iniziare che l'operazione ragazzi
allora primissima cosa ricordatevi
rimuovere la parte superiore perché
quasi un chiodo nel dubbio lo impianto
martella come se fossi thor bravissimo
se non stiamo facendo
raga ricordatevi sempre che la parte in
superficie va rimossa subito col
martello molto delicatamente e dopo si
fa passare all'interno del nostro
paziente benissimo naga direi che
possiamo passare alla parte un po pi
casina talora innanzitutto mi dovete
spiegare perché io scholl trapano tenuti
in questo modo lo sto sventolando tipo
una bandiera a leo non penso che sia in
vena di festeggiare cazzo va bene devo
riprenderlo in modo un po più ok
aspettate naturista allora piano vai no
kat
il trapano no
che cazzo ne va bene ragazzi faremo
averlo del trapano maledizione va bene
rack andiamo di seghetto soccorso rega è
partito uno strumento essenziale ma
ricordatevi che ci sono sempre le
alternative
seguiamo lo stomaco ok allora vai così
piano piano piano si sta morendo ma
inizio via via via tutto sia tutto
ragazza in questa scendendo troppo
velocemente sta se ne cazzo cazzo libera
libera
ok è stata ancora ragazzo sta soffrendo
sta soffrendo in faccia lì a devo fare
vaio probabilmente gliela devo fare
nell'occhio
penso che fu
nicosia raga se devo essere sincero non
so effettivamente dove infilarli st
siringa qui però è deve fermarsi a ok si
è fermato bene si è fermato il sangue
fantastico grazie ragazzi per avermelo
detto nello scorso episodio che dovevo
fare così
e cos'è questo questa roba qui cos'è
cos'è sta roba qui è un boom della stava
cos'è
[Musica]
che cazzo di figata non ci credo non
cazzola il laser merda
raga laser selvatico nello studio merda
aiuta ragazzo sta segando il paziente a
metà il mio polso maledizione visto
tagliando un braccio cazzo ok fermo
brutto stronzo ok ci siamo piano piano
che mi sembra di essere luke skywalker
benissimo rai allora dobbiamo rimuovere
cazzo lo stomaco del paziente con laser
però è un po un casino perchè devo il
paziente sta correndo
senti zio come va con gli occhi non è
che mai bisogno di un laser novero non è
che io mi sembra mi sento veramente luke
skywalker così va bene cadevo devo devo
segnare lo stomaco alla lega facendo
così il paziente dovrebbe tornare in
vita credo lo stop perfetto se ce
l'abbiamo fatta
reg ci voleva un test per per il laser
ovviamente come faccio a sapere come si
usa
se non lo testo almeno una volta vai
così ragazze la sto facendo
ho rimosso praticamente è tutto tranne
questo qui d'affetto ce la stiamo
facendo quanto sta di sangue noi che
siamo messi bene allora devo rimuovere
fermo lì fermo di non fare non agitare
la spada
devo capire che partì rimuovere allora
abbiamo rimosso il prezzo dello stomaco
perfetto allora forse forse dico forse
non ne sono sicuro si toglie allora via
quella roba via allora dobbiamo riuscire
no kat
maledetto dove vi sta morendo
si sta morendo e pozzi armi a via
colombo prendi la siringa
prendi la siringa lettera si metta la
cazzo no nell'occhio all'occhio c'è
nell'occhio
dai dai vivi stronzo mini vivi non
morire ci sono raga lo impugnata c'è è
la prima volta che in puglia una stringa
da dio perché effettivamente si
impugnano così non ci posso credere
allora ce la facciamo
ce la facciamo a vedi non so neanche
dove glielo sta iniettando ma glielo
spettando via da qualche parte basta che
smetti di sanguinare
ok ce la stiamo facendo la casta
rallentando sta rallentando
l'altra volta se la poco fermano
riprendendo ok va bene così va bene così
piano appoggiamo la tranquillamente
senza trovarci perfetto raga sto
tentando di togliere lo stomaco in tutto
ovvio
cosa ho fatto ce lo fa ok siringa dove
la siringa dove la siringa dove la
siringa l'ho buttata muoviamoci che sta
morendo ce l'ho fatta male in chiave a
tutto via tutto che cazzo devo riuscirci
quanto mi manca tipo na minuto scarto
vai via
togli tutto ragazza siamo dove togliti
bastardo come si toglie sta roba come
faccio ora ce la devo fare male iniziare
sta morendo era che una cosa mica mi
sembra che devo disinnescare una bomba
porca [ __ ]
il lavoro del dottor e stressante dove
la dove l'infermiera che mi passa al
fazzoletto sulla fronte che sto sudando
maledizione come siccome si tolgono i
reni porca [ __ ] come faccia latri via
sottovia e adami qui cos'è una coscia di
pollo questa pianta gli era sto cazzo ma
porca [ __ ]
in un'edizione come faccio la che aiuto
aiuto raga e non so come toglierlo vado
di baci vado un po più su pesante mai
così taglia fa qualcosa ragazzi sta
morendo
chi sta morendo non può morire non mi
morire adesso maledizione ma dai porca
put a siffatta non ci credo raga
impossibile ok ragazzi sono di nuovo sto
messo abbastanza bene stavolta col
sangue
devo riuscire allora io non so
precisamente come si muovono i reni
penso che debba tagliare il filo giusto
quello blu a quello rosso cosa esplode
va bene è l'orologio ma è caduto dentro
ma ricordatevi se il paziente non vede
rene non duole
era un po diversa la cosa ma non importa
vai così allora dobbiamo tagliare bene
stiamo facendo
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta ho tagliato
serpente di gomma non so neanche come ho
fatto
non ci posso credere toglilo cazzo
dragon share non qui dentro via via
tutto porca [ __ ] che schifo allora ce
la possiamo fare vai
bene allora vediamo tutto quello che in
eccesso togliti pancreas di merda come
si toglie togliti maledizione kabul sana
va bè quello lo togliamo dopo la coscia
di pollo prima a dir la verità raga mi
sembra un alieno cazzo che cazzo ci ha
dentro visitors ok via via tutto è
sveglio per caso cioè perché non lo so
sei sveglio o sei sveglio non è sveglio
raga ce la stiamo facendo
l'operazione era arrivata nel momento
più delicato ragazzi dobbiamo togliere
allora quanto ci rimane poco poco poco
allora dobbiamo riuscire a togliere i
cosi i reni a rimpiazzarli innanzitutto
dobbiamo togliere la roba che perfetto
non è questo non è questo il metodo
giusto
devo togliere la roba perdere il filo
verde sempre quello giusto e se ce l'ha
fatta
ho tolto un rene devo togliere l'altro
come si toglie l'altro faticose ce la
posso fare
sta morendo rubiamo c proviamoci
minimale tipo un minuto vai così via un
rene [ __ ] chi se ne fotte
vai anche con l'alto prendi lo veloce
velocissimo ragazzi mica se ce la faccio
ce la faccio appello vai vai e prendi
maledetto stronzo devi prendere un rene
non puoi essere così impedito cazzo va
bene non importa va bene così facciamo
con tre reni ma godiamoci allora prendi
di tutti e due insieme no che va bene
una volta non importa vai col primo vai
col primo vai col primo michael ii
raga tre legni tre legni svegli che juan
è meglio che tu veramente a me non
importa vai così ma spinge riso raga
aiuto a trarre nick che cazzo dai che ce
la faccio
dai che ce la faccia dai ancora 11 nomi
morire non vi morire no no no non ci
credo
ragazzi ha lasciato adagiato nel momento
sbagliato il cazzo che mancava un
ragazzo abbiamo provato non fa niente
nel prossimo episodio non sto a rifarlo
perché tanto eravamo arrivati lì
quindi dragano il prossimo episodio
faccio direttamente trapianto di
cervello voglio veramente non vedo l'ora
di vedere le ambulanze cielo per essere
in ambulanza ma soprattutto quella nello
spazio sarà epico sono sicuro io direi
di chiuderla qui salvi dove è piaciuto
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che come in ogni
video trovate la descrizione se non
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi invece
vediamo in un prossimo vito bella
ragazzi
[Musica]